it's my pleasure to welcome you here
Frankie lectures the Frankie seminars
and the associative lectures are a very
very interesting program here the way
that was that was funded in 2004 by
Richard barber Frankie Richard Barbara
often have paid lectures today
unfortunately
these the the funding enables enables a
professor or team of professors to teach
a seminar course that doesn't enable
them on top of that seminar to curation
and important aid a small lecture series
perhaps sometimes they're good films and
screenings and I have there have been
other things as well but usually it is a
small lecture series and the
distinguished lecture series where
fantastic people from outside do have
brought in to speak on the topic or
around the topic of the seminar this is
it's it's a picture of them there is a
quarter there was a parallel program
called the Shulman seminar which is
specifically while the Frankie seminar
in the humanities the Shulman seminars
are at the border of humanities and
science and these two are have the same
lecture series associated with the
mogollons seminar and it's a wonderful
experience because it brings it brings
the external scholars into into
conjunction with the undergraduates in
the seminar in a close way over dinner
in a seminar and then also gives us an
opportunity for a public lecture from
our visitors
Martin Eglin who is this year's convener
of the of the Frankie seminar this year
topic being in time and that Martin
introduce our speaker just a moment I
just wanted to go down just a very
quickly a few of the the the topics that
we've had in recent years Nietzsche and
Emerson was organized by Paul North with
Paul Graham Sam in 2013 utopia by John
Rogers in 2014
interpreting film masterpieces by the
Dudley hundred whom I think I saw Andrew
and David Bromwich 2015 James Baldwin's
Americans seen Jackie Goolsbee in 2016
so this was an extraordinary
extraordinary woman New Orleans and the
American the American and imaginary last
year Joseph fishel and Krystal Fenster
it's an eclectic group of seminars they
can go in all kinds of different
directions but they are fantastic
experiences we think for the public that
comes to the lectures for the
undergraduates that take a seminar as
well I hope you won't agree thank you
[Applause]
thank you Gary
[Music]
we've all been having
we've already have a very lightly
seminar so I mean one of the great
themes of the bank yes Gary beef you
mentioned is that like not only do these
people comment are they actually
participating in seminar and today yeah
we're not getting into any details yeah
it was very violent active even when
they were serious yeah so so so it's
always been a very intense thing I'm
excited to continue with that with a
talk yeah so Taylor Carmen is professor
of philosophy at Barnard College in
Columbia University and he's the author
on human morning books
the hydras analytic from 2003 and
merleau-ponty from 2008 a measles edited
the Cambridge companion to novelty and
published a number of important articles
on Heidegger terminology Cannell
philosophy the intersection philosophy
on our syllabus and we have no less than
two chapters from Taylor's book assigned
and several of his articles and there
are many good reasons for that and let
me take few things just about first of
all his book I'm finding from 2003
highest analytic that has the remarkable
feature of both one of the best
introductions to being interviewed in
reading and also one of the most
advanced books from being time you can
read and that's a very rare feat to do
those things at once you know I'm always
very comfortable recommending in both of
students who are starting out reading
being in time and those who have come
very far and want to really deepen their
understanding of the thorniest issues in
the book so and the same is true of
Taylor's articles on how to go to yeah I
mean I met recently that Heidegger
apart from Aristotle there's no loss of
Ferb has been enormous Heidegger but
since by that quantity is a very select
group of scholars who am actually able
to both translate the states of what I
was doing in this very difficult
language into general philosophical
concerns and also yeah make explicit for
us that despite that intake is so
difficult
it has direct purchase along with our
lives and Taylor is one of the few
people who can do both of those things
he has an amazing ability to combine
film optical description with conceptual
analysis and that's also why he's been
such an important voice in the dialogue
between comes now
the approaches behind her and also one
of the reasons that the few times we
lucky that tail adventures happen also
talking about art or literature he's
also extremely sensitive we go to these
things and I think we'll see some of
that today as he's taking on both the
big conceptual question or what I
believe by truth but also how that can
be brought to bear on questions of
narrative truth toriel truth and perhaps
most suggestively well thank you so much
for the invitation to come and speak
with you and to you about about
Heidegger and being in time and related
issues and for the very lively seminar
we had earlier I'm still sort of
catching my breath thank you for the
invitation the humanities centers very
as I say honored and happy to be here
I'm going to be talking about truth and
I have several different purposes that
have all sort of converged so I hope I
hope the the result is clear I want to
talk about truth with respect to what
Heidegger has to say about truth but
then I want to extend Heidegger's idea a
bit in a direction that he didn't that I
think he should have and could have but
I also want to talk about narrative and
truth in narrative and specifically how
we ought to understand truth in
narrative so as to possibly resolve some
debates about whether and to what extent
narratives or stories can be true of
human lives
those are my purposes my my main purpose
is to say that if we extend heidegger's
concept of truth in the right way we can
understand what it what's really at
stake in trying to tell a true story
of somebody's life in say a biography
the title I gave you some months ago was
pictorial
and narrative truth and I'm gonna have a
lot less to say about pictures today
because as I've been thinking about this
over the last few months I've just
gotten more interested in questions
about narrative but on your handout at
the bottom I did include a picture which
I was gonna talk about which is Francois
g.low and Picasso's portrait of her she
was his not wife but girlfriend and the
mother of two of his children and she
wrote this fascinating memoir called my
life with Picasso she talks about this
picture that he painted of her and I'm
gonna say a little bit about how and in
what ways it's true it's obviously false
because she was not a plant or a flower
but it's true in another way but I'm
gonna really be talking more about
narrative but I'll start with I'll start
with truth and with Heidegger so
Heidegger famously draws a distinction
between two concepts of truth and those
are the two you see more or less in the
left and right hand columns in the upper
part of the the big box there over
underneath the big Greek word Alafaya
which is the Greek word for truth and
it's the it's the Greek word that
Heidegger picks on in order to as it
were promote his own idea of truth in a
left-hand column there as unconcealed
meant but he distinguishes famously
between these two concepts of truth the
first is the traditional notion of
rightness or correctness wastage kite in
German which is the simple common sense
concepts taken for granted by but not
identical with its philosophically
theorized offspring the agreement or
correspondence conception and that in
German is a branch the moment I
distinguish those as isn't often done in
the secondary literature but Heidegger
does sometimes in his better moments he
he often refers to the correspondence
conception of the correspondence theory
this is what philosophers have been
talking about for a long time the
correspondence theory of truth it's
really not mostly what Heidegger's
interested in the correspondence idea of
truth a belief or a proposition
corresponding to what it's true of is a
philosopher's invention it's a
philosopher's theory it goes back as far
as Aristotle
I don't think it goes back any further I
don't think there's I don't think
there's any evidence of it before
Aristotle you can press me on that if
you want to Plato says things that sound
like it but really they sound as much
like what's called the redundance theory
just to say what's true is to say of
what is that it is and if what is not
that it's not and to say what's false is
to say of what is that it isn't in so
long and those tautologies Plato says
that it doesn't sound like
correspondence to me as much as a kind
of redundancy theory but that is a
theory of truth understood as
correctness and that's not a whole
meiosis but there in the top box or
thought ist's which means correctness
Heidegger's word again is very tight and
as I'll say in a minute
one can in some contexts translate racy
tight into English as accuracy and I
think that's what Heidegger has in mind
the ordinary notion is truth as accuracy
that's the first concept that's the
traditional concept not so much the
theorization of that concept in the idea
of correspondence but you already find
the conception of correctness in Plato
for example in the theaetetus Plato when
he talks about false judgment he says
false judgment is like an archer missing
the mark and there the metaphor is
you've either hit the mark Eve missed
the mark
notice there's no talk of mirroring or
correspondence or agreement an arrow
doesn't agree with the target it just
hits it or it doesn't
that's the primitive notion that's
really what Heidegger is mostly
interested in in sort of the history of
thought so I think the correspondence
conception is a bit of a red herring but
as we'll see it can interfere with our
idea of what it is for a story to be
true of a life so something like the
correspondence theory as I said can be
found in Aristotle but the simple notion
of correctness is explicit already in
Plato and though Heidegger was in fact
slow to admit this it can also be found
not theoretically or explicitly so much
but just in the use of the Greek word
aller thea in the Iliad so at one point
Heidegger thought that Plato had
invented this notion but it's others
have pointed out it's an ordinary Greek
going back to Homer the second concept
Heidegger zone concept is what he
variously calls
closeness - lawson height or unhidden
nasaw run concealment in feb organ
height is the german term this concept
is very different from correctness for
one thing it's opposite is not falsity
but obscurity concealment oblivion this
means that even when things are showing
up in wrong distorted or misleading ways
they're still true in Heidegger sense of
the word my memories may be incorrect or
inaccurate but as long as they are
memories and not wishes or fantasies my
mere having of them discloses my past to
me as that about which my particular
memories might be true in the ordinary
sense of the word or false so my memory
is disclosed avow and there's a truth in
that so Heidegger says another mark of
the distinctiveness of the concept of
unconcealed is that like illumination it
comes in degrees whereas at least
traditionally truth and falsity are
polarized or bimodal the middle is
excluded famously if you've ever heard
of the law of excluded middle there's no
excluded middle in concealment and
unconcealed meant there's almost always
only middle and in fact to come to think
of it Heidegger central thesis about
these two concepts of truth is that the
first presupposes the second correctness
is intelligible and so even possible
only against the background or on
condition of unconcealed meant what make
son concealment worthy of the name truth
though that's the questions a question
that his student ansatsuken hot pressed
is unconcealed really a kind of truth or
is it merely one of its presumably many
conditions of intelligibility Heidegger
equivocated about this for years from
his early formulations of the
distinction in the 1920s and most
famously in section 44 of being in time
to finally the 1964 seminar the title of
which is the end of philosophy in which
he finally conceded that it was as he
says inadequate and misleading to call
on concealment truth as he had been
doing for the last 40 years
or so so by 1964 he just says okay don't
call it truth well that's giving up well
is it giving up a lot that's the
question
faced with this apparent disavowal we
have several options the first at one
extreme is to cling to what I think is
the least plausible interpretation of
Heidegger of Heidegger's position namely
that he wanted to destroy the concept of
correctness and replace it with his own
notion of truth as unconcealed meant and
just do away with the notion of
correctness and and only talk of n
concealment I don't see how he could
possibly have thought anything like this
John Salas for one has proposed that
since things can indeed must be only
partly unconcealed concealed and
unconcealed at once
Heidegger must therefore be denying the
law of non-contradiction a lot of people
seem to think Heidegger denied the law
of non-contradiction but I don't think
he did that's at one extreme but I don't
think that's what Heidegger had in mind
another extreme the other extreme mark
Rafael was a great commentator on
Heidegger has argued that the apparent
recanting in the 1964 seminar was really
just a matter of terminological
housekeeping and that by calling
unconcealed its truth as he had
previously done Heidegger never meant to
say more than that it is the ontological
condition of the possibility of
correctness you just got to have on
concealment I have correctness for
sentences propositions beliefs to be
true or false
something must first of all be showing
up now the problem with this approach I
don't have a knockdown argument about
this reading of Heidegger but it is
disappointingly innocuous it's not
strictly speaking trivial but it conveys
none of the excitement promised by
Heidegger's original claim that there's
more to truth truth itself then either
the metaphysical tradition or
contemporary common sense had hitherto
imagined the second problem is that
being time is replete with concepts that
could equally claim to describe
existential conditions of correctness he
talks about being in worldliness the
worldliness of the world understanding
discourse interpretation there's all
kinds of things that are conditions
of the correctness of a proposition or
belief with respect to what it's about
and even disclose admission section 44
of being in time he says is really
that's designs disclosing this is the
kind of truth that he's really
interested in even that term was already
doing other systemic work in the text
prior to its appearance in section 44 as
specifying this new ontological notion
of truth so too can hots question is a
good one
why call this truth right so in this
paper I want to try to vindicate in a
way that I think Heidegger himself never
fully managed to do his you might say
promiscuous maybe even perverse use of
the word truth to mean unconcealed
as well as correctness the two notions
are distinct
I shall argue but deeply interconnected
however we actually decide to use the
word simply clinging to tradition by
denying its application to unconcealed
it which is what when you run up against
mostly when you talk to philosophers
about this they just say that's very
interesting but it's not truth giving up
the idea that there's a sense of truth
which is something like on concealment
carries a cost and moreover I think does
violence even to our common sense
understanding of truth in non-discursive
contexts for example in narrative in
pictorial forms stories and pictures
that is especially portraits and
biographies have a way of getting it
right about their subjects not by
representing them in factually accurate
ways but by being true by being true to
them to the subjects revealing them as
they are by being faithful to them and
this is what I mean by truth as fidelity
a biography a picture a portrait can be
true to the subject it's a kind of
faithfulness but it's also a way of
getting it right and it reveals the
person so I think these are cases in
which it seems to me the traditional
concept and Heidegger's concept really
overlap or converge and that we need
both to make sense of a kind of non
factual truth it's a kind of rightness
that is not the sort of correctness
which is accuracy and Heidegger never
made this distinction maybe partly for
linguistic reasons but I think mostly
that he was just interested in drawing
this distinction he wasn't so much
interested or just didn't manage to
justify putting them somehow together
under the same word ilithyia so notice
that I said stories and pictures can be
true by getting things right in a
distinctive non factual way well but
isn't rightness just precisely wastage
kite I mean it's a translation of
Vistage kite which is Heidegger's word
for correctness and here I want to
exploit the lexical resources of English
which is conveniently for me a hybrid of
Latin and Germanic vocabularies right is
Germanic correct comes from the Latin
correct tools now JL Austin at least
according to John Searle I don't know if
he ever says this anywhere in print but
I heard John Searle say Austin said
there are no perfect synonyms I might as
well add when I heard sir will say this
Searle said but there's one exception
and it is and I can't remember what he
said and I've emailed him several times
saying do you remember when you said
there was one exception there's two
words that are perfectly synonyms in
English and I haven't heard back from
him this may disappear in the oral
history of this part of philosophy but
oh well I'm just gonna stick with there
are no perfect synonyms so I think this
is a case in point in some contexts as I
said earlier one can translate the
German lipstick as accurate I mean one
can translate accurate in other ways to
can how exact and so on but obviously
not everything that can be said to be
right can be said to be accurate it was
right of me to apologize but my
apologizing was neither accurate nor
inaccurate so right is just a much
broader term than accurate I think right
to my ear sounds broader than correct
even though they should be synonyms I
mean you can say that it was Mike
apologizing was correct that's a little
bit more
English it sounds like I'm doing
ordinary language philosophy here and I
don't really mean to be but it's just
kind of illustration and I'm not resting
my case so much along other words fall
out so one could say that my apologizing
was correct and in German actions as
well as propositions can be either HT or
false polish in German can be translated
into wrong right in English it's not
impossible to call an action false it's
not very usual but one can say you know
then one false move and you know that's
false but the standard term would be
wrong an action would be wrong rather
than right but wrong now being though a
Germanic word strangely there's no
cognate in modern German as there is in
Dutch in the Scandinavian languages all
of which is to say that although it's
possible that Heidegger included
practical and moral rightness under his
concept his general concept of a
steatite he seems to have had more
interest in factual rightness than in
the rightness or wrongness of conduct or
character and my point here is just that
he draws a pretty sharp distinction
between correctness like shish kite
maybe even a cumin a sense of accuracy
and on the other an unconcealed meant
and I'm trying to say there's another
category there's there's extra room
under the category of rightness that
allows us to bring in something like on
concealment or revealing ok but I don't
find this third concept and this is what
I'm introducing in the in the lower box
here the non factual kind of rightness
that we can find say in pictures or
stories it's a kind of research kite but
it's not what Heidegger seems mostly to
with that in mind when he talks about
Ritchie's kite namely correctness or
accuracy I'm thinking of it as a kind of
faithfulness or fidelity or being true
to so one could say loyalty toya which
is of course etymologically linked to
true but I don't find this concept at
least I don't know if it occurring in
Heidegger but I think it promises to
bring together these other two concepts
that Heidegger does talk about truth
truth is fidelity being true to the
matter at hand
reveals it does it justice shows it to
be what or in the case I'm interested in
who or somebody is there's a way of
getting it right that is precisely a
kind of revealing or showing of them
okay so what is it to get it right about
who somebody is I want to quote I want
to quote somebody quoting somebody I'm
quoting Raymond Gaeta who I'm gonna
discuss in just a minute who quotes
Isaac Dennison Karen Blixen saying you
asked who he was let me answer in the
time-honored fashion and tell you a
story so telling a story is a way of
saying who somebody is and here I refer
you to the next section of my handout I
just want to distinguish three things we
can have in mind when we say I know who
someone is the first two are relatively
trivial because I'm interested in the
third but just to put our ducks in order
what is it to know who somebody is in
the first case its knowledge by
description for example knowing that
Homer was the author of the Iliad that
that may be the only thing we know about
Homer I mean there's a joke that says if
if the Iliad wasn't written by Homer it
was written by a blind Greek poet of the
same name right so but but I want to
include in number one pointing to
somebody and say oh I know who that is I
know or a name I know that so-and-so is
the author of such-and-such description
knowledge number two is knowledge by
acquaintance but I don't mean what
Bertrand Russel meant by that quite I
think it's fine in fact I'm committed to
a distinction between knowledge by
description and knowledge about
acquaintance Bertrand Russell was
thinking of sense-data
that you know them by having them the
mistake he was making was with the
objects he was picking out I don't think
we have knowledge by acquaintance of
those kinds of things but I do think we
have acquaintance knowledge which is not
knowledge by description so what I have
in mind is knowing somebody by
acquaintance being acquainted with the
person in which an ordinary common sense
just means having met them if you say do
you know someone
you would say well I've met them right
this is more than just having a
description and there's a big transition
from just reading about somebody to
meeting them when you meet them suddenly
you have a whole different relation to
them just by being in their presence
hearing them speak watching how they
move and so on this is an important
distinction I think there's a big
transition that happens between just
reading about somebody thinking about if
you could meet Socrates it would be a
big difference between just reading
about Socrates so there's a big
difference between knowledge by
description and knowledge by real
acquaintance not Bertrand Russell kind
of acquaintance but actually meeting
somebody that's fine but I think there's
also a very important distinction
between that and what I want to call
intimate personal knowledge which is not
just having met somebody but actually
knowing somebody what do you know when
you know somebody this is what you know
when you've gotten to know them and this
is also why interestingly when somebody
says do you know someone you say well
I've met them but I don't really know
them right I mean there's a big
difference now not that there's a split
second where you transition from having
met them to knowing that how many times
you have to speak to them before you
know them but it's not that there's a
sharp cutoff but there's an important
conceptual difference there's a point at
which you feel that you can say I know
this person right you've talked to them
enough you get to know them there's
something you know that you didn't know
before okay so that's the kind of
personal but intimate personal knowledge
that I'm interested in and that I think
narrative but also pictures have
possibly an important something
important to teach us about maybe I'll
come back to France well as you low at
the end but let me talk about narrative
a little bit okay some historians and
philosophers are attracted to the idea
and have been for a long time that our
understanding of human life must
necessarily be a narrative kind of
understanding so there's a debate that's
been going on for I don't know I don't
know the history of this debate but some
decades about narrative visa vie lives
and identities characters the what you
know when you know who someone is by the
way let me just say is a footnote those
of you in the Heidegger Simon
can can connect a lot of what I'm saying
to heidegger's categories when Heidegger
talks about design he talks about the
who of design right and this is partly
what I'm addressing who is somebody it's
it's a fundamental category of our
understanding of human beings that we
understand us ourselves as who rather
than what that's a deep ontological
difference and partly what I'm
interested in exploring here so some
historians in philosophers are attracted
to the idea that our understanding of
human life of the who of design you
might say must necessarily be a
narrative kind of understanding some go
so far as to say that human life that is
life in its distinctively human form I'm
talking about animal life but human
lives lives in the biographical sense of
the word has an essentially narrative
structure that lives just are structured
alexandrina Hamas's wonderful book on
Nietzsche is subtitled life as
literature
I think he's committed to a view a kind
of narrative estuve you of human lives
Alastair MacIntyre in after virtue
another great book rights narrative
history of a certain kind turns out to
be the basic and essential genre for the
characterization of human actions and
he's building on Elizabeth Anscombe zyc
ount of the intentionality of action
according to which action is
distinguished from a broader range of
behaviors or doings by being done under
some particular description not just
anything that might be truly said of it
but what captures its proper aim and
relevant context of performance not
everything I do is an action of mine so
although I am exerting force on the
floor with the weight of my body and
making noises what I'm doing in the
proper action sense of the word is
giving a lecture McIntyre's pithy
statement of the narrative hysteresis is
that as he puts it stories are lived
before they're told Barbara Hardy went
further when she wrote and this is this
is really Richard Moran quoting Alastair
MacIntyre quoting Barbara Hardy Barbara
Hardy says we dream in narrative
daydream and narrative
remember anticipate hope despair believe
doubt plan revise criticize construct
gossip learn hate and love by narrative
now these claims both Hardy's and
McIntyre's seem to me vastly overstated
and in what follows I want to defend a
modified view of the the the modified
version of the opposite view call it the
anti narrative Vista view which has
recently been interestingly criticized
by Richard Moran in his 2015 Aquinas
lecture entitled the story of my life
it's in his recent collection of essays
called the philosophical imagination
Moran finds the anti narrative Vista
view articulated by fictional characters
such as dusty Huskies underground man
who is a complicated case because it's
very hard to sort out whether what the
underground man says is Dostoyevsky's
view about anything or whether it's just
symptomatic of a kind of pathology but
dusty up skis underground man doesn't is
hostile to the very idea that any
description of him could be true let
alone us a story I'm gonna leave the
underground man alone just for now but
another good example is rock on Tana the
hero of sart's novel nausea rock Anton
presents a clearer case for what he says
bravely but with no small dose of
melancholy is that life is not made up
of what he calls adventures or stories
at least not for the person actually
living to life unfortunately as moran
rightly says this leads him to the more
skeptical thesis that no story can
really be true life doesn't have the
structure of a story so stories always
get it wrong narratives inevitably
distort and indeed falsify the lives
they purport to describe another source
in this debate is Hayden White's classic
the fiction of narrative which defends a
similar anti narrative estuve you at
least the idea that narratives are
always fictions never get it really
right now Richard Moran argues that
these skeptics go wrong as skeptics
often do by taking for granted and
inappropriate standard of truth or
success and it's something like a
correspondence Theory right to be true
lives would have to have the structure
of store
and they don't so stories are always
false that's simplifying but that's the
gist of the view and I think Moran is
right to criticize this if stories
always or inevitably get it wrong about
the course and structure of human life
what criterion of rightness are they
failing to satisfy such skeptics Moran
says when they talk about the diversity
the difference of perspectives that is
the perspective of the narrator and the
spec the perspective of the liver of the
life right from my point of view my life
doesn't have the structure that the
narrator of the story of my life has
I'll refer you to another memorable line
from Kierkegaard which once I saw it I
see it everywhere everybody likes to
quote this and it's a wonderful little
remark character guard says life can
only be understood backwards but it has
to be lived forwards right so if you
replace understood with narrated I think
he's exactly right right there's a
retrospective structure of narrative
different from the future 'el
perspective you have as a real person
that is the different that difference in
perspective is important now Moran says
the skeptics the anti narrative ist's
are correct and insisting on this
difference of perspective but they're
wrong to interpret that as meaning that
the retrospective or external
perspective as this perspective of the
narrator must be false to the reality in
question and I think he's right about
this that difference of perspective
doesn't mean that all stories are doomed
to be false
according to Moran it's not narrative as
such but particular narratives that fail
to tell the whole story or an adequate
story of a person's life narrative does
not fall short of the real non narrative
structure of human temporality he argues
that's to say the skeptics think life
has a non narrative structure and so
narratives always get it wrong but I
think he's right to say this seems to
suppose that narratives could only be
true by having the same structure as the
lives right by mapping onto them or
mirroring them somehow but
so his suggestion is that you shouldn't
think that it's narrative as such that
fails to capture the as it were story of
people's lives it's simply the fine a
toot of particular narrative
perspectives that falls short of the the
multiplicity of perspectives that in
fact makes up the dramatic complexity of
human life and he concludes his essay by
considering an example the example of
Oedipus you all know the story of
Oedipus he doesn't know what's going on
in his life until the very end
Jocasta knows before he does and we the
audience know way before he does and the
the difference of perspective is what
makes it look like as a liver of a life
the story that someone else might know
about your life is not available to you
so what Moran says is this whole complex
that makes up the story of Oedipus the
whole story is not lived out by any
character in the play and couldn't be
the only perspective that could
encompass them all is that of the
audience who's outside those events and
not just spatially and temporally but
metaphysically interesting right you
have to be metaphysically outside those
events to really see as it were the
whole story well you'd have to be he
says he's not a character at all and
play no role in the events recounted so
so his suggestion is that it looks like
narrative is inadequate but really what
that means is that no one particular
narrative is ever going to be adequate
there's always going to be a
multiplicity of perspectives and from
any one perspective another perspective
leaves something out and the perspective
of the agent or the person the subject
of the story is always going to be
unavailable to the agent
now I think it's interestingly
symptomatic that he's considering a
fictional case and a case in which
there's an audience and I want to talk
about a real case of a narrative a life
of a life and just quickly I will say I
think that there is a structural problem
more than just the diversity of fine
narrative perspectives the structural
problem is a little bit like what
Kierkegaard had in mind and it's a
problem with narrative as such it's a
problem we can only see though if we
resist the temptation to say that
narratives can be true only by
corresponding to mirroring or matching
the supposed narrative structure of
human action and human life itself I
think there's a reason to say that human
life has an important lien on narrative
structure and that's why no narrative
king can capture it though of course
stories can be true so I want to say
precisely by seeing what this
distinctive kind of narrative truth is
what it is for a story to be true namely
fidelity to its subject only by seeing
that can we see what is necessarily non
narrative in life itself so if we really
understand what it is for a story to be
true that is not by matching the
supposed intrinsic narrative structure
of a life only then can we appreciate
how life fails to be narrative that's my
promise to you I'll get all I'll flesh
it out now as we go so as I said I think
it's interestingly strange that moran
ends by saying the audience could see
the whole picture maybe God can see the
whole picture but it's not available to
us what about a real case the remark of
Karen Blixen when she said you asked me
who he was let me answer in the
time-honored fashion and tell you a
story is quoted by Raymond Gaeta who was
an Australian philosopher who wrote a
memoir about his childhood and his
parents he quotes this remark in an
essay a philosophical X as a reflecting
on his memoir which is called Romulus my
father and that really was his father's
name it wasn't a dramatic title he
didn't know what to call the book and
his father's name is Romulus and
somebody said why not call it Romulus my
father what a great title right
stumbling upon a fantastic title but
that was his name the but his father was
Romania Romania
from a Romanian speaking part of oh dear
somewhere in Yugoslavia I think oh right
because I'm really feeling it that's
what matters
yeah exactly so so Romulus is not such a
strange name in Romanian speaking
cultures perhaps the book is a stark
deeply affecting account of Raymond
Gates's parents troubled life together
his mother's insanity and suicide but
above all the person the life history
the talents the strengths and the
weaknesses in short the character of his
father the effective power of the story
as Gaeta himself observes he says at
least he hopes comes from the
truthfulness the seriousness the
integrity of the narrative it matters
that he neither buries unpleasant
episodes noir fiction Eliza's details
for dramatic or simin sentimental effect
he says he's really trying to get it
right but it's not accuracy as such that
establishes the books moral and
emotional integrity perhaps more
important than the facts themselves
Gaeta suggests is the tone of
seriousness that he brought to the
telling of the tale the attitude of
respect indeed love for the characters
he describes in all their frailty their
humble virtues the tragic arc of their
lives the truthfulness he sought in
writing the book was as much a matter of
mood and style as of factual correctness
and again those of you who are reading
being in time you think of the finished
kite or a tournament or mood which
Heidegger had earlier associated with
Aristotle's rhetoric setting a tone a
mood very important and this is what
Gaeta says he was especially trying to
do to get it right about the story of
his father to show you who his father
was
to resort to cliche or to indulge in
sentiment for example he says would have
been a kind of failure in fact a kind of
falsity a betrayal of his responsibility
to bear witness to the lives of his
parents with the full seriousness that
they deserve
in resisting pathos Gaeta says and I'm
quoting him I was not trying to get the
feeling out of the writing I was trying
to make the feeling true so false
sentiment I mean sentimentality it would
be false feeling it would get the story
false so he's a nice discussion of the
difference between how sentimentality
can interfere with scientific research
if somebody's sentimental it may lead
them to overestimate the intelligence of
animals and they're getting it wrong
because the sentimentality of their
attitude towards animals is causing them
to get it wrong about the facts whereas
somebody who buries their dog in a fancy
cemetery with a tomb and has a
sentimental view that this is how a dog
should be treated you might say you
don't have to bracket whether you agree
or not this might be a kind of
sentimentality which is not causing a
kind of false attitude but is a false
attitude to the dog the sentimentality
is getting it wrong itself about dogs in
their relation to us just suppose you
agree with the judgment you can flesh
out the details of the case to make it
unpalatable enough that you agree that
this is sentimentality to the point of
falsity rather than sentimentality which
has diverted your judgment from getting
the facts right in a scientific inquiry
so it's vital that we hear Gators use of
the word true when he says I was trying
to make the feeling true he's using the
word true in a way I think that combines
three distinct but interconnected senses
genuine or real like true as opposed to
some good examples of true true grit
it's real grit and true real teeth as
opposed to false teeth false teeth
they're not real teeth that's genuine
but faithful that's the sense that I'm
most interested in true to the subject
but also right and that's ray she's
tight in his broader sense then
Heidegger I think had explicitly in view
gave his aim was to be true to his
father not in the sense of honouring him
or defending his reputation but by
respectfully and I think it's important
to say lovingly getting it right about
who he was to tell a story that would
show who he was which is what he wanted
to do however he would have to go
beyond what fact and reason could
determine for example so here are
open-ended questions which fact and
reason can't decide was in in paying the
rent for his estranged wife and her
lover and their baby was his father
proving himself to be a generous soul or
a pathetic cuckold I mean you could tell
the story either way and it's
interestingly under determined by the
facts gauges reflection on his memoir
make it clear make clear I think what
ought to be evident in any case and he
doesn't say this but I'm saying it on
his behalf
no one other than Raymond Gaeta could
have written this book romulus my father
and not just because of the title but
because it's his testament to his father
no one else was in a position to say
just what Gaeta had to say about who his
father was
moreover the rightness of gatas
testament doesn't necessarily entail the
wrongness of a conflicting account even
one that might seem to contradict it for
example in its assessment of his
father's character now I'm not going so
far as to say that two stories that
actually do logically contradict each
other can both be true but I think you
can get very close to something that
looks like a contradiction that at least
is a conflict that forces you to choose
one story or the other but they can both
claim to be true so it's a little bit
like in commencer ability of paradigms
in Thomas Kuhns account of science they
can be genuinely in conflict not so that
you can show that they are logically
contradictory but in such a way that you
can't just easily put them together with
the conjunction and say it's one big
story
you can't put these stories together
you're either going to tell a story that
he was a pathetic cuckold or you can
tell the story that he had this
extraordinary generosity but you can't
really tell I'm supposing you can't
really tell both stories and make it a
single coherent story the kind of truth
the gaeta was aspiring to is not factual
accuracy but it has its own kind of what
he calls objectivity and I would
hesitate to use this word but
he uses it and by that he means he says
nothing fancy philosophically fancy but
as he says quote seeing things as they
really are or better as he says he was
doing quote trying to see things as they
were rather than as they were constantly
appearing to me I did not want to
deceive myself so he's trying to be as
honest but also true to his father
recognizing his father strengths and
weaknesses not as I said papering over
difficult issues but also being
genuinely faithful as a witness to the
life of his father so that he could show
you who he was
that's my concrete case now what do I
want to say about that what's important
about that is precisely what I think
distinguishes my third level of knowing
who someone is from the second level
that is and I didn't say this before but
when you get to know somebody and you
know who they are they're no longer as
it were a third person but a second
person I mean what's the condition of
your saying that you actually know
somebody rather than that you've just
met them it's that you've actually
talked to them and they've talked to you
and you have a second person relation to
them and in that having that second
person relation to them you share enough
of their view of the world how they see
themselves and how they relate to their
future that you share with them the
relation to the future that cannot be
captured in a neat story now let me
finish just by saying a little bit more
I didn't say this before I guess I
should have this debate about the
possibility of narratives being true of
lives a lot of it hinges on what you
think counts as a narrative so the
people who defend the narrative estuve
you it often turns out they'll accept
almost anything as a you know
description of a person a series of
events as being a narrative and so if
you make the concept of narrative
capacious enough it'll almost be
trivially true that when we understand
each other we understand each other
under the aspect of narrative but I
think the claim is only interesting if
we distinguish narratives or stories
from some other kinds of descriptions
the description that Hayden White
distinguishes is
he calls the Chronicle a mere Chronicle
is just as it were a list of events so
everyday you could fill into the log or
the blog today this happened today this
happened today this happened what you
would have wouldn't be a story it would
be a list of events that's not enough I
think a narrative to be interestingly
different from any other kind of
description has to have something like a
turning point which forces you to see
retrospectively things differently than
you saw them before the turn
that's what stories usually have
something like a turn that'll that
recasts your view of what led up to the
turn and this is a structure that can be
present in very concise form in jokes
jokes have the structure the the reason
that joke works is because by the end
you see the beginning differently and
jokes can be very short so narratives
don't have to be long drawn-out Affairs
so my favorite example for the moment
Henny Youngman the master of the
one-liner had a joke which I think has
this kind of structure this
retrospective structure in a single
sentence I don't know if any of you know
the joke it's a conditional it begins if
I'm not in bed by 11 o'clock
say no this joke if I'm not in bed by 11
o'clock I go home okay so you see the
beginning differently than you saw the
end it works as a joke winced I think
nobody laughed but okay gee alright I
thought it was funny doesn't matter if
you think it's funny you see the
structure right even bad jokes are jokes
but sometimes they fail because they
just don't even work right I mean
they're just not so when somebody is
somebody bad at telling stories you hear
then this happens then this then this
and at some point you want to say where
are we going with this right it's a
series of events and this is this
affects debates about history and
narrative and stories like his history
one damn thing after another or does it
have this kind of narrative structure
built into it so I think for the claim
about life having narrative structure
there has to be at least some content to
the notion of narrative that keeps it
from the distinguishes from mere
descriptions of a series of events and
that's just what you can
only due retrospectively but when you
get to know somebody to the point that
you can say who they are you know who
they are you can say who they are in the
form of a story you are necessarily
sharing enough of the view of the world
with them that you share their sense of
the future which is never going to be
encompassed into a story until after
their life is finished and you can look
back on it from a point of view which
they are excluded from so this is this
is really the point I want to try to
make I think what's right about the anti
narrative is view is that the future all
structure and again is very high to
garyun theme but the future all
structure of existence is precisely what
cannot be understood in narrative form
because it's open-ended it's uncertain
you can predict or forecast things about
your future which turn out to be true
but it's almost a grotesque accident if
the story you tell yourself about the
future turns out to be true let me end
with one example of this example I sort
of want to try to generalize you know
the Scorsese movie the king of comedy
the character is kind of a pathetic
loser he's I may be 30 he's living in
his mother's basement he wants to be a
comedian he wants to be a talk-show host
he's got this fantasy about himself he's
telling himself a story about his life
about his future he and his friend
kidnap the Johnny Carson kind of star
characters played by Jerry Lewis they
hold him hostage they negotiate a deal
where he gets to host the show and to
become a star and he managed to do that
and he's a big hit and he becomes a star
in his own TV show and it's grotesque
and horrifying right because his his
fantasy narrative of himself turns out
to be correct but you sort of want to
say it was a kind of grotesque
coincidence right I mean that's not the
way the future is lived by us as we
project into it unless it's this kind of
grotesque coincidence that's an extreme
case and I'm using it just to make that
point rather vividly that stories are
retrospective but
you you are in a position interestingly
to tell the truth about somebody's life
if you know them well enough that you
share the future or perspective with
them that is precisely what can't be put
into a story so as a biographer and
possibly as a as an artist painting a
portrait your you face this dilemma
which is that to tell the story of their
life you in a sense have to alienate
yourself from it in a certain way and
that's a just a dilemma that's built
into the genre okay I'll stop there do
we take questions or what do we have
what's the format do I call them people
or I can I can certainly yeah um Martin
first okay yes okay right so um well
there's a lot to say about well so the
main point that Heidegger wants to make
is that not so much that the traditional
concept is wrong in fact he doesn't even
really say the correspondence theory of
truth is wrong I think he thinks it's
just kind of useless as a theory it's a
theory of correctness but he's not
interested in rejecting that concept of
truth but he wants to say it's only
intelligible to us thanks to this other
phenomenon which philosophers have
missed which is the showing up of things
and the things show up perception
reveals a world there's just a world
that's always already there about which
a belief a proposition a sentence can be
true or false which you can have an
accurate or an inaccurate view of and
Heidegger calls that condition of
correctness truth and he likes to use
the Greek word but what he means by it
is unconcealed meant as opposed to
concealment I tried to
say a little bit about how that works
differently from you yeah yes that's
right and other philosophers have talked
about conceptual frameworks or languages
vocabularies they're not correct or
incorrect but you're having them shows
things up about which you can have
correct or incorrect opinions or beliefs
or so on yes so you know just a culture
lets things show up differently right so
here's an example I heard Bernie
Williams talk about you know how some
words die out and are no longer part of
our vocabulary because they don't reveal
anything
chastity used to be a very different
kind of concept in the Middle Ages from
what it is now now it's a kind of in a
way trivial concept you don't make much
use of it because I mean what is it and
who is chaste and who'd who cares right
but it used to be a virtue they used to
really there used to be a very thick
moral kind of language about chastity it
wasn't just about whether or not you
were having sex it was a character
quality that ramified and when you don't
have that term in your language but in
your system of thought you don't know
how to apply it and I think his idea was
we don't we wouldn't know long we've no
longer how know how to describe people
as chaste or unchaste we don't know how
it ramifies into other aspects whereas
the people who had that part of their
thinking and part of their language knew
how to apply it to people or not and
whether you were right or wrong and
applying it because it was showing
things up in a way that allowed you to
entertain those judgments yeah there's
many examples from different
philosophers if you know Foucault when
talks about Epis teams you can think of
those as revealing something within
which people can disagree it's very
important for Foucault that that the the
disagreements that are really the
deepest disagreements people seem to
have or possible only because they share
something like an epistemic
heavenly bodies corresponds to the
number of holes in the head we don't
even know whether to say that's false or
true you just can't even take it
seriously right but that was a serious
claim it was a it was thought to be
plotted and some people might have said
no that's false
but only they could do so only because
they were taking it seriously yes so on
concealment is is that kind of
manifestation of something or other
about which a belief could be true or
false
now Heidegger was so interested in
saying that that the the unconcealed
Minds is a condition of correctness and
it was important point to make that by
1964 he didn't seem to have too much
invested in whether you call that by the
same name as what is the condition of so
Marc Roth all whom I mentioned just says
don't worry about whether you call it
truth and Heidegger seems to say this in
1964 what's important is that you can't
have truth in the traditional sense
without that unconcealed now I think
what he seemed to be surrendering there
was this idea that the ordinary notion
of rightness which is the opposite of
wrong and not the opposite of hidden is
a broader notion than factual accuracy
and it needs to encompass something that
also coincides with a way of kind of
revealing so portraits can be revealing
of the person in photography as much as
painting you think that picture really
captures the person as we know bad
photographs snapshots with people's eyes
half-closed and their tongues hanging
out and you know they that doesn't
capture the person even though there's a
sense in which it being a photograph
it's almost by definition accurate
brutally accurate now these are all
kinds of platitudes but I think they're
cases which maybe suggest that Heidegger
should have tried a little bit more to
say how these two concepts interact or
overlap so that we can think about and
this is what Raymond Gaeta is thinking
about in the case of his memoir what it
was to be true to write truly of his
father and I'm suggesting it has
something to do with fidelity to
his father being true to his father and
more specifically knowing him well
enough that he sees the world as it were
through his father's eyes so that he can
appreciate the kind of future which is
precisely what resists being packaged in
the form of a story or a narrative I
want to bring in the issue of the
fictional character and I'm doing
through reference to person I've read on
these things which is poverty rates
about editor a lot and his essays on
storytelling he wants to relate the
storyteller the fictional storyteller to
the historian that both doing the Sklar
yeah saying and the fictional
storyteller knows when he gets something
wrong about a character ladies invent a
interesting in the same way that
historian knows when he's going in the
archive when something is pertinent hmm
you see the need of reference out there
or want to have one that people could
check on I see where as recruits they in
fact the same thing applies somebody
yeah no that's fine with me I don't I
don't mean to restrict it to that and
I'm sympathetic to the example yeah I
suppose you could yeah you can talk
about that's fine with me
yeah I'm writing a novel and I'm you
know as flow bear is writing about
Madame Bovary and maybe a certain point
he gets it he gets it wrong about her
it's a different thing of course I do
think that there's real important
differences I mean it's a matter of
coherence and and consistency and but
it's as if he knows her that's okay I
let's see what else do I want to say
about that the difference just is that
whereas in the real case there's loyalty
truth is fidelity to the person but the
realness of the person is also tied to
their actually being facts about the
person's life which there won't be in
the fictional case that is an important
difference now I don't know what to say
about the relation between what I'll
call the
factual accuracy and the and the
fidelity can can a biography or a
portrait be faithful without any regard
to the facts I don't think so but yeah
okay no actually you know good good let
me let me refer you to the portrait just
quickly so Francois Jalloh who by the
way is still alive lives in New York
she's in her 90s and she talks about
this painting in her in her memoir
Picasso was competing with Matisse here
because Matisse had painted someone as a
flower and Picasso wanted to paint
somebody's a flowers so he paints her
now
I think god it's gone brick who refers
to this picture and points out
interestingly that and the story that G
lo tells is that Picasso got it got it
wrong over and over again couldn't get
it right now of course in the sense of
loyalty or faith fidelity because you
know how do you get it right if you make
her a flower or not but it didn't
capture her and it wasn't until he
turned the face 90 degrees so you'll
notice she has a very vertically oval
kind of face and it wasn't until he
turned at 90 degrees and made it
horizontally oval that he got it so the
reason it's a nice example is because
it's precisely by getting it wrong that
he gets it right now I think the other
reason it's a useful example is because
you could say well look it looks like
her because there's that spot under her
left eye and that's there and there's
the eyebrows look similar in the nose is
a similar [ __ ] you can point to actual
similarities and say I'll see there's a
factual accuracy there which is really
doing the work but I don't think that's
just what's doing the work I think gum
bridge is right that it's the horizontal
positioning of the face that somehow
captures the shape of her face and
captures her expression and does it so
there's a kind of truth that I think is
in its own way primitive and not
reducible to accuracy and the the way I
would want to sort of generalize that is
to say I do think some resemblance
our primitive Vic and Stein has a nice
example where he says if I show you two
pictures of trees and I say what do they
have in common you can point to the tree
and say there's a tree that one there's
a tree in that one but if I tell if I
show you two shades of red and I can say
these are two shades of red what do they
have in common that that allows you to
say they're two shades of red you can't
point to anything it's just that you
know that so so I think some
resemblances are like that the one thing
just looks like another but you can't
point to the thing in virtue of which
the one resembles the other and I think
maybe this fidelity is a little like
that it's it's I don't want to reduce it
to a notion of resemblance but there but
you have to be able to see in the
biography you have to recognize the
person right you have to say yes that's
him you got it right that really is who
he was or she yeah mm-hmm
okay let's see maybe in the back there
yeah yeah and then I'll come back here
[Music]
fine with me and I think it's it's why
religious belief hasn't just evaporated
once the factual truth of its doctrines
seem to be no longer tenable it's
precisely because something else is
going on like paradigms or vocabularies
or frameworks religious vocabularies or
religious belief systems can make things
show up a good example of this in sort
of modern half religious half secular
society is Dostoevsky when he talks
about fathers Oh Seema there you get an
interesting conflict between the way
religious belief and
and scientific beliefs are competing for
showing up the way the world is like so
when I was talking about a chaste person
what about a saint can somebody be a
saint what would it be for somebody to
be a saint
Dostoevsky I think was very interested
in that what would that look like or
does our scientific and secular
vocabulary make sainthood a totally
outmoded concept you know though assume
it was supposedly healing people but
then it turned out he was giving them
drugs
so does that just undermine your faith
in him altogether
it's a problem so so I think that's one
way to understand a kind of truth in
religious belief is that it's it's it's
even though possibly factually
inaccurate and just false it allows you
to see things you couldn't see before a
religious vocabulary might attune you to
human suffering and promote compassion
in a way that you can't do if you're
just thinking in terms of medicine or
mental illness by the way another
example from Raymond gatas book is that
his father after his mother's suicide
had a kind of mental breakdown and was
in a kind of Institute and he went to
see him his father when he Raymond Gaeta
was 15 and he said it was a really it
was a watershed point in his life
because it was a kind of traumatic
adjustment from the sort of vocabulary
in which he understood his father's life
which was through the lens of philosophy
and tragedy and now in terms of met you
know psychological diagnosis and
medicine and nurses and doctors there is
a whole different set of categories that
seem to not do justice to who his father
was
it was a kind of violence to the sense
the head of his father's life which he
tried to preserve in his in his book
that his father had this kind of tragic
life a view of life he describes his
father's view of the world in terms of
what he calls a compassionate fatalism
it's deeply compassionate but he was
also fatalistic I want to go into too
much detail here but it was a tragic
view of life that he Raymond Gaeta
understood that the medical sort of
vocabulary
of the asylum just was incapable of
comprehending so I'm all for that but
let me say I'm all for it but I'm also
all for metaphors being true in this
sense right metaphors are another good
general example of how you can get it
right by not just in spite of getting it
wrong but like the picture you get it
right by getting it wrong I think that's
fine because it's revealing
yeah I mean Hegel was as we know
notoriously optimistic about the idea
that reason could then sort of you know
recover and recapture these truths at a
higher level level articulation and that
the there'd be Liz this consistency and
so on I'm much more of a I won't say I'm
a pessimist but I'm more impressed by
the incommensurability z-- between these
different ways of understanding and and
that there are metaphors religious
beliefs stories that are never going to
be comprehended entirely just as Gaeta
says just by reason or science and that
these will never be all harmonized
that's what I but that's just my own
perspective let's see here you
oh yeah accurate but not yeah I didn't
say this at all but that's right it
should be obvious that there's all kinds
of factual truths that are totally
unalloyed and this is a kind of
platitude to like there's all kinds of
true facts that are just not interesting
they don't answer a question I mean
there are some historians at the very
positivist end of the discipline of
history who have said quite seriously
any fact you can add to the historical
record is a contribution to the study of
history like how many stones are there
in this road from one city to another
you've made a contribution but it's a
pretty absurd view so yeah how many
blades of grass are there in the lawn
over there in the square who cares
there's all kind as we know you can
mislead people by sticking to the facts
in one particular way so it just seems
to me absolutely in vital that we think
of truth is involving an aspect of
revealing that's why I'm always so
disappointed that hydrogens say more
about how rightness itself is right by
revealing and not just that the one kind
of category is call it truth or not is a
condition of the other this is like an
unfulfilled promise I think in his what
he says about it let's see now oh so
many hands please guess I'm sorry yeah
no you're right
did I miss your point though I mean
[Music]
well maybe you could say this yeah I
mean what it does is reveals Oedipus's
ignorance I mean I guess you could say
that right I mean it really underlines
his blindness I'm not sure what to say
about that I thought your point just was
truth in the sense of correctness
needing to be revealing which I agree
with but before there can be a story I
don't think there have to be turns in a
life in order for it to be understood in
any way let me be clear about that
I don't think stories I don't think
lives have to enact structure of a story
in order to be understood I think we can
understood yes now we can understand a
life without recording to narrative form
I think it'll be virtually impossible
because by the time you get to any kind
of complexity and a life unfolds there
will be occasions for these stories to
happen and it's almost so I just think
as a practical matter their stories all
over the place to tell about just what
happened to me today and I can tell you
and when we I mean the Barbara Hardy
quote that I said we do all these things
in daydream and we and gossip and love
and hate she's right about gossiping
right
I mean gossiping is trading stories
telling stories that's fairly loving and
hating I don't know that we'd love and
hate in story form so I don't want to
say that lives have to do that I think
they inevitably will just because with
enough events happening and as things
change perspective changes enough
retrospectively that it's a very natural
and almost unavoidable way to talk about
each other into each other in story form
so it's all over the place it's just not
as it were ontologically essential I
think and it's particularly in relation
to the future it's just not the
structure of our relation to our future
that's I guess what I want to say yeah
okay Wow I don't know maybe in the way
back
yes okay so I'm in between them and the
narrative is I think in a certain way
because Galen Strawson x' idea I think
really is that there isn't necessarily
an answer to the question who was this
person
the I think what's moving about gait as
discussion of his own memoir about his
father is that he thinks there's a
question to ask and an answer to be
given now what I meant to say was
there's not just one answer to give
because only he could have given the
answer he gave when he wrote the book
about his father somebody else would
have told a different story and said
something different so it's the
knowledge we have of people knowing who
they are will be perspectival it'll be
essentially perspectival in the sense
that there will be multiple and probably
competing and conflicting stories and no
one of which can claim uniquely to be
the truth
but what I like about Gates's view and
this is this is different from what
Strawson says I do think that it's a
meaningful question to ask and to try to
give an answer to that you can say who
somebody is you can say it by knowing
them only by really knowing them when
you know them you know who they are and
you can say something about who they are
and there is something to get right or
not get right but it's not a matter of
just the facts now the other thing I
want to say though is
that as you say the structure of our
relation to our cells is different to
our relation to others so I also have a
relation to the question about myself
Who am I and going back to those of you
who are in the Heidegger class that's
the question from the first person point
of view which has a different structure
I think a crucially non-narrative
structure Who I am is what's at stake in
how I'm living my life how I'm
projecting into my future but I have to
project into my future to be dealing
with the question Who I am and there's a
sense in which it's always a kind of
open-ended question so but that's the
same the same question this is something
again Heidegger doesn't really talk
about much that I'm asking the same
question of myself that somebody else
would ask when they say who was he
really right so I do think there's
structural difference between the first
and second person is important yeah yep
[Music]
oh I need to say with respect to the
future I'm projecting into of course I
can of course I can take up a narrative
point of view to my life up to the
present of course yeah now I don't mean
to be denying that at all no no probably
not but but not because lives just are
intrinsically narrative in their
structure but just because given the
unfolding of a life over time it'll be
virtually impossible for there not to be
stories and and that story is a genre or
a form in which we make sense of
ourselves I only want to deny it this
sort of bedrock metaphysical status I
want to say that it's typically one of
the basic ways in which we make sense of
ourselves but it has this retrospective
structure which keeps it from being our
way of relating to our future except in
this like King of Comedy way where we
tell ourselves a story and maybe it'll
turn out to be accurate and maybe it
won't be but that's sort of it'll be a
matter of luck whether it does or not I
would say for Heidegger's purposes
there's probably going to be something
just inauthentic about trying to live
your life into the future by already
having the story that you're planning to
tell retrospectively by the end of it
you're not in a position to have to
narrate the story of your life into the
future but of course I agree that up to
the present moment it's a very natural
thing to do to say here's the story of
my life it's something I want to think
about a lot more I think autobiography
is a very strange genre it puts you in a
very awkward position being both the
narrator and the liver of the life that
you're that you're talking about there's
a tension there
I think but sure of course with respect
to the past absolutely I will again say
there's not going to be just one story
there's gonna be a multiplicity of
stories there's gonna be a multiplicity
of stories from different perspectives
what it is to be true to your own story
I don't that's a that's a I don't know
what to say about it so hopelessly
complicated
fidelity to your own story I it may just
be that there's something almost
impossible about that but I don't quite
know what to say about autobiography as
it's in this isn't okay one more it's um
not surprising that it's just about the
most difficult zone right - right Ian
right
there's write an autobiography it's a
huge challenge it might seem like the
easiest thing to do probably the hardest
one more question does somebody feel
like they had their hand up a long time
and I've missed them just we want to
make a special case oh yeah
that was sort of my name thisis really
it absolutely matters which doesn't mean
that the narrator has to agree with
everything but there has to be a
commonality of view enough that you've
that the narrator somehow inhabits can
partially inhabit the view that the
person had of himself that's what I
meant to be saying yet that that's
essential but and this is why it's very
difficult sometimes for biographers when
they get to know their subjects too well
they might feel like now they're no
longer in the ideal position to write
the biography they don't have enough
distance they're too close to the person
right so being too close to the person
precisely because you share their view
of themselves may keep you from knowing
how to tell the story anymore
but what I wanted to say was his love
for his father is what was allowing him
to be truthful about his father is
making it difficult in some ways but it
was the condition so so he Gaeta is very
sensitive as he says he wants to tell it
like it is he wants to try to tell it
truly with the true feeling to see
things as they are not as they kept
appearing to me so there's a very
important distinction between appearance
and reality I should have said this a
long time ago what what allows us to say
that there's an issue of rightness in
the telling of the story is that you
feel that you are susceptible to
mistaking appearance for reality so just
as you say the mirror image is going to
be not good enough but now that distant
distinction as it were between
appearance and reality should not be
understood in the sense that the reality
is the soul of the person which is a
private intrinsic feature of the person
not in relation to me I think what we
can be right about behind appearances is
constituted by the relation to the to
the second person
so we shouldn't let the difference
between getting it right and getting it
wrong or seeing how it really is as
opposed to appearances lead us into
thinking that we're getting behind a
veil of appearance to an intrinsic
reality which just is what it is
independently of its relation to me the
narrator I think it's because he has his
son and he loved his father that he can
tell the story as it is and not just as
it appeared to him so so it's absolutely
essential yeah somebody once said I
don't know who said that somebody said
it to me could be nobody important that
you can only really take a good
photograph of somebody if you love them
now that may be sentimental but there's
something not completely wrong about it
it's like you've got the relation to the
person that you there's an intimacy that
it allows you to capture them that you
don't have if you're stranger to the
person yeah okay thank you
[Applause]
[Music]